- Today I'm going to give
you a quick book contest
update as well as some
exciting announcements.
(upbeat music)
What's up, Believe
Nation, welcome to another
edition of Evan's Book.
I'm excited to dig into the contest.
I've had it for the past
two weeks on the channel
to have a contest to give away
10 signed copies of my book
for people who create some art around it.
I'm actually filming this on
Wednesday, my normal filming
day, which is December
28th, and so I can't
announce the contest winners
yet because I want to give
a little bit more time for
you guys to create some art.
So, I know this is coming
up to you guys live already
on January 2nd, but I'm filming
it December 28th, so next
week I'm going to be picking the winners.
Good luck to you all!
I'm excited to see what
you have come up with.
While I've got you here,
though, I wanted to also share
a couple of exciting
announcements that I have
for the book series and
see what you guys think.
I'm going to see how I feel
about them, but here are some
of the ideas that I'm playing
with, so first off is going to
be the book club hangouts,
doing a weekly series for seven
weeks for each chapter of
the book to help people
along the way, where you guys can join in
on the live hangout, ask me
questions, chat with other
Believe Nation members
who are reading the book,
because I really, again, want to make sure
that people are reading the
book, they understand it,
they're getting the value from it,
and so anything that I can
do to help make sure that you
are getting value from it,
you're taking action on it,
you're actually reading the
book and applying it to your
life or business, I want to
make sure that gets done.
That series may continue,
may just be a one-off, seven
weeks, that's it.
It may be an ongoing thing
where we repeat it again and
maybe have some special guests
come in who are in the book
or people who are going through
the process of reading the
book and helping them live.
I don't know, playing with some ideas.
I'm open to some feedback, but
that's going to probably start
right after we finish the contest.
Some other ideas that
I had were to do some
book reaction videos.
A number of you have sent in
the videos of you unboxing
your book or sent in a thank
you message, and I thought
about smashing all those up
into one video, 'cause they
made me feel so good and happy
when I saw them and to give
some love and exposure for you
guys for making the videos,
I might do that, so also pro
tip, if you guys are making
reaction videos, send them to
me so they can be part of that
mashup and get some
exposure on the channel too.
I'm thinking about making a
what I learned as a message
to myself for going through
this again, 'cause there's been
some things I think I did really well
in launching this book, and some things
that could definitely
be improved next time
around that I need to remember
in case I do it again.
I need to watch this video back.
It's a message from Evan, from
past Evan to the next Evan
when I'm going through this
again to do these things
because it could've been
so easy and could've saved
a lot of headaches, so
I'm already planning that,
so it's another idea.
And then the last one I
had, at least on my list
of current ideas, is to
do a series of from rookie
to best-selling author, and
every week kind of comparing
how my book is doing
against a successful author.
If you look at Tim Ferriss or
Brian Tracy or Tony Robbins
or anybody who's in the business
of personal development,
taking my book and matching
it up and seeing how well
we're doing against that
author, and then also taking
a bit of advice from that author.
What has Brian Tracy or
Tony Robbins said about
book promotion, and then me
trying to go out and do it,
and then reporting back
the next week, is something
that's on my mind.
It's a ton of work to put
that together, but I'm kind of
curious to see, and I like that idea,
from rookie to best-selling author.
So, those are the things
that are on my plate, some
of the things that I'm planning
in 2017 for the continuation
of this book series.
Good luck to all the contest entries.
Next week will be the grand
reveal of who wins, so I'm
excited for that, and I'm
curious to hear your thoughts
about future video ideas.
What did you think about
the list I threw out there?
Like it?
Leave it?
Do you have other thoughts
that you'd like to see me
talk about in this book series?
Leave it down in the comments below.
Thank you guys so much,
every week, for watching.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for everybody who's
picked up a copy of the book
and enjoyed it.
Mad love, mad love, mad love, so much.
I believe in you.
I hope you guys continue
to believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.